missus hey Jack are you all excited for  our trip yeah and look what I found this  is so cool is this the same spot we're  going to I hope so  and look I think that's what we're  taking the boat tour oh I love it  look I'm gonna go chat with Melissa but  you're setting up the party room right  yeah I got it thanks you later jack All  Right see you later bye hey girl  guess what what I got the apartment Wow  nice look at your balcony I know it's  amazing  no roommates I have it all lined up the  lucky blue couch yeah this table with  this floor perfect Jack keeps calling me  can we talk later  sure bye  [Music]  okay hold this balloon could you know we  got to do it  [Music]  don't forget your back  [Music]  [Music]